were you surprised at how big a part you
were in alchemy no because clearly right
when this movie is announced we were
talking about it earlier today that
basically everybody in Breaking Bad
except Jesse Pinkman died right so it's
got to be relying on flashbacks to some
extent so you don't nobody would really
know what characters are gonna play how
big of parts or whatever and and I mean
a big chunk of the movie is kind of a
buddy film almost you know between your
character and Jesse Pinkman did you have
any idea before you got the script how
big a part you were gonna play in it I
assumed it would be a scene yeah - you
know I thought it was gonna be pretty
brief because that's sort of the way it
was in the show he kind of floated in
and out um and then I read the script
and you know what I didn't leave the
show feeling like I had a bunch of
unanswered questions with Todd and then
I read the script
and then all of a sudden my mind was
reeling again because it did in my mind
what was always exciting about the
script was it kind of shows Todd and I
really messed up weight kind of having
one of the best days that you've ever
seen him have because Uncle Jack's gone
you know it's like parents are away
right it's me and my pal Jesse right
he's gonna we're gonna have some road
trip is gonna help me get the rug off
the balcony little task for us do you
know when you're looking at when you're
looking at a script like that do you
know when you encounter a line that
you're like oh I can make this the line
cuz I feel like that literally the best
line in the entire movie was when us
Jesse what's your favorite kind of pizza
yeah yeah yeah just the context and the
way it said and everything do you know
when you read that you're like okay I I
try not to think about the way the line
might sound you know but that scene in
particular was just so well written and
we shot that in the painted desert in
Arizona
Vence was nice enough he's a flies
helicopters and he invited Aaron and I
to take a trip out there from
Albuquerque to to the location was he
flying alone or was there an instructor
there was an instructor but he's an
incredible pilot I mean as diligent as
he is in his work he's he's just annoy
you when somebody is like really good at
multiplying hellas Christ I just want to
get one thing down yeah you got one of
the greatest show runners of all time
where the greatest writers I'm also very
good at five gallon I wonder ripe I like
take a helicopter lesson it was the was
a doors open it were they close they
were closed how high I couldn't tell you
good six there was there was one point
when the instructor took over and you
know did some sort of military-style
maneuvers for what reason to show you
this tub just for fun Gary I probably
shouldn't have said that
did you enjoy it or were you like we got
to lay in this helicopter man it was it
was pretty great and I mean it was just
we saw a wild horses it was crazy so was
he doing like just dropping and point
yeah we got a load of the pretty low to
the ground yeah did you ask him not to
do that
no okay you figured like I'm with Vince
Gilligan if he's not gonna die it
Aaron's here to like if I was in danger
these guys you wouldn't be with me so
gives you a giant celebrity on the plane
like there's no way we're going no way
I'm gonna be a part of that guy's story
never happens I probably should rethink
that all the time in plane crash when
you get back into that Breaking Bad
world and like you know years back into
that space is there a party because I go
yeah this was a really good time Vince
would you maybe maybe we should keep
doing Breaking Bad movies maybe we
should
I after after that day in the desert I
just I feel like this is kind of Vince's
directorial debut and he's such an ink
he's an incredible writer and creator
but he's such an amazing director and
his eye visually and he's the nicest
person I feel like I've met and and this
line of work and I hope he continues to
direct movies I hope he just finds some
some idea completely unrelated to the
world and creates something else you
know you watch the preview watch out
better call Saul I've seen a few
episodes yeah I need to I think it's
pretty it's pretty good I mob Loden Kirk
he is [ __ ] goodness yeah it's a good
show and and it still carries on
basically what happened in your show we
were talking earlier your turning point
we thought on we liked it better call
Saul is like a good sequel to his show
it's a prequel oh I say it carries on
like a make sure you know it's
incredible yes a prequel that still
makes you think of the other show we
said the turning point and when you're
on Breaking Bad is when you shot the kid
on the bicycle well your character but
it changed the whole show it that was
the whole series yeah
turning port where you're like oh we're
not having fun anymore selling meth
fighting right we just that one action
right well your character shoots that
kid it's like there's no and the
character has even realized that the way
they react we can't undo that there's no
turning back
yeah and the kid didn't know he's gonna
get shot when he auditioned for the part
they think I'm on Breaking Bad they're
gonna use me as oh and all the side like
no you
your character turning around and being
like why you guys you guys told me
nobody was supposed to see us it was the
character it was so calm like it yeah so
when you do everyday is shoot a kid on a
bicycle I mean if they see you we're
here for a mission we can't have people
getting in the way did you have any idea
like the death scene was gonna sort of
reshape the entire series III knew
reading that episode that it was one of
the best episodes of television of the
best scripts I'd ever read I mean just
reading it your heart was pounding and I
knew it was significant and at that
point in the show I mean I had so little
information from anyone about Todd I had
just a sort of a an analogy from vents
to sort of base everything off of but it
did it felt significant yeah what is the
analogy well he I mean I was cornering
every writer to try and get some
information from them because in the
previous episode I just sort of give
Walt a tip about a camera and in this
house and that's about all you see so I
was asking Vince you have to like you
have to give me something
who is this guy how does he just
casually shoot this kid and he just said
you know when you're driving and if you
swear there's a raccoon runs out in
front of your car if you swerve to the
right you run into the ditch if you
swerve to the left you hit a car what do
you do
and that was it really does you shoot
the raccoon you shoot the raccoon
there's not great to know those
sometimes like with with with series
like that that you're watching a show
right and you're looking at this
character going like what's this guy's
deal and you don't know that there are
times when the actor is going like yeah
I don't know either that's a perfect
explanation note so you got to do it ut
the lesser of the evils the fastest way
just through it and without getting hurt
any more than you have to and just
pragmatic to the utmost yeah you know
and you know I think there is maybe a
hint of Gilligan in there you know maybe
I'm just sort of and he really has an
affinity for Todd - yeah one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM f
[Music]